well let's return to our top story the
coup in Niger Mahmoud bazoom was
hand-picked by his predecessor he also
held several ministerial posts before
becoming president
takes a look back now at his political
career
when Muhammad bazoom was elected
Nigeria's president in April 2021 there
was hope the first Democratic transfer
of power would be the start of a new
chapter for the West African nation
in a sit-down interview with Al Jazeera
bazoom acknowledged the Deep wounds left
by years of political instability but a
new era he said would follow
it will be difficult but not impossible
I think difficulties are behind us we
succeeded in a democratic change of
power it was our biggest challenge
things became less difficult from that
point onwards because of this I believe
that yes we will succeed
a philosophy teacher turned trade
unionist bazoo mentored politics in 1990
co-founding niger's party for democracy
and socialism
he came from a minority ethnic group in
the country's Southeast and highlighted
his election as proof it was possible to
overcome Division
I symbolize a hope simply I hope the end
of the ethnic issues and the
relationship to power yes I think we
have helped our country and ourselves a
lot we certainly could also serve as a
model for other African nations
Niger is no stranger to military
takeovers analysts point to Poverty
persistent insecurity caused by armed
groups operating in the Sahel region and
widespread corruption
an ability to fight corruption that has
been a major challenge for West Africa's
democracies and that almost consistently
almost legitimizes
the military's desire to end a
corruption is the big elephant in the
room back in 2021 just days before
bazoom was sworn in the Army stopped a
coup attempt this time the threat came
from within the presidency now millions
of people are left wondering if Niger is
heading down the same path as neighbors
Burkina Faso and Mali governed by
military rules
Al Jazeera
well joining me now in the studio is
Baba welder he's Al Jazeera arabic's
West Africa correspondent Baba as we've
been hearing bazoom's election in 2021
was New Year's really first Democratic
transfer of power since Independence how
is he viewed now how popular is he well
it's difficult to measure the popularity
of outside president Muhammad bazum we
know certainly that yesterday some of
his supporters tried to to protest in
the capital near me in
refusing what the presidential guard his
decision by the presidential guard
yesterday but they were discussed by the
by the presidential guards and really he
there has been no such let's say popular
um Uprising against him along over the
last two years he was quite popular was
considered the Niger was considered as a
even in that in that uh religion yes yes
table up relatively stable but they
could secure this political transition
from Muhammad useful to byzum something
that many countries failed to do over
the last years such as Mali Burkina Faso
and also so in a Chad the night bring
Chad to the east of uh Niger so it was
somehow popular he had these supporters
his ruling party we cannot measure
how he is now because the the
Constitution is no longer in effect in
the country and people are not able to
demonstrate except if they are
supporting what the military uh the code
that has the military has stated
yesterday it is so far well so far been
a bloodless coup do you have a sense of
what's triggered this
will we know that president was
detained early morning yesterday and
there are hours passed and probably
there was such let's say dialogue
between the presidential guard and the
rest of the military uh battalions uh
especially outside of the capital near
me and the the military succeeded to to
avoid this budget to avoid this
confrontation as the military declared
few hours ago that they are backing the
move taken by the presidential guard so
that to the academy puts
so that they can avoid any military
confrontation between the different
battalions of the Niger Army well we
know that the the presidential guard
initially said this was about economic
mismanagement because of Insurgency in
the Sahel that was also being mismanaged
we know that Niger is obviously in a bit
of a tough neighborhood right and and
militancy has been increasing across the
region so this could have some very
broad implications for a lot of vested
interests
yes but Niger
Ian situation is current situation is
not different from what it has been
a lot over the last let's say 10 years
military has been ravaging the region in
in Niger as well as in Mali in Burkina
Faso and large ideas of and regions of
these countries are out of control of
the control of the uh the the the the
the the the capital uh Authority uh and
also for economic uh situation and life
conditions they have never been quite
good initial a lot of all its decisions
it's it's independence in 1960 uh it's
one of the poorest country it's true
it's a living it's going through a very
difficult time over the last two years
but there's nothing let's say special
about the real of uh Muhammad bazum it's
not that different from the country has
lived through a lot over over the reign
of uh uh muhammadu Yusuf over the last
10 years so it's it's always like that
include that has in West Africa it's
always
worsening conditions difficult security
situation it's something that comes
together with akudata in that tradition
very common reasons given then yeah Baba
World Homer Al jazeer is Al Jazeera
arabics West Africa correspondent thank
you so much for for joining me here in
the studio for our NewsHour my pleasure